[Music]
me
i'm just in the little bit the bottom
says consider joking the channel i
really do need to proofread things
before i click go
hi guys and welcome to sidetrack and the
machine hello hello
i'll explain quickly what we're doing
today because we are on sidetrack
channel and we're on the machine and
we're on the twitch account today
because we are talking about
fire in the sky that the travis wallston
walton ufo institute
the waltons is this was was this related
to the waltons i never really watched it
uh no
no okay
a little bit um
so
obviously there was the movie fire in
the sky
so today we're gonna basically ask the
question was that movie
based on a real event
or is it just a nice bit of sci-fi
because actually it did get nominated
for five saturn awards when it came out
fire in the sky it did it did quite well
as a movie it's star db sweeney
whose career never really took off
because he's got a weird face
and somebody might have heard of called
robert patrick he's done quite well
henry thomas was in it from e.t fame
and um the legend
james garner was in this movie so this
was a little tin pot movie this this is
a proper film when it was released so um
here is a little clip from the
advert before i make
a um
an admission about this this thing
considering i'm a ufo person
here we go
[Music]
the story that travis walton and five
other witnesses told was so unbelievable
so unimaginable
that it has become the most famous case
of ufo abduction ever reported
[Music]
there you go that was the outfit
finished film i love that movie
everyone's in with it today hey andrew
hey shelly
let's get into it though right so my
admission quickly i am a bit of a ufo
guy we have this to the term we talk on
the machine we talk about ufos and
supernatural things and whatever hell we
want to talk about please go over to the
machine and um subscribe if you're
watching this through scitrek or twitch
um there's a link in the description
there's also a link to stormy's channel
if you want to see more of him
if you want to see more as well let me
just adjust my camera because i can see
what it's saying
um
so
i don't know anything about this story
i watched this movie when it came out
probably about 28 years ago
and i can't really remember it so
today stormy and davey have
graciously accept um accepted the
responsibility of explaining the story
to me reminding me
and then we will figure out
is this
sci-fi like star trek star wars just a
load of you know made-up story or is it
actually based on a true story
guys dave i think you're going to start
i think and then
um he's just going to jump in and make
stuff up as he goes along yeah well
that's the best way of doing things
really isn't it making it up
because i'm american
is it is it power for the course because
it's this story made up well i suppose
there's only one way to find it really
and then here's two hold it in man
jay hold it in swallow man
nearly choked jeffy
you love it really christ he's awake
this is dead
i'm telling that more than the actual
story of the film really
um
but trump okay so travis waltern was uh
a logger
um he was 22 years old at the time
um and on november the 5th 1975
he was um logging with five five
teammates in uh on near snowflake in
arizona
um
in the
apache
si si si grieves apache something
national park you have to excuse me for
that particular bit
um
and they were they were driving they
were driving back after finishing late
at night it was dark and they noticed a
glow what appeared to be a golden glow
in the sky above the trees
to the extent where they even sort of
like uh remarks like it looked like
there was a fire and we could see the
reflection of the fire within the sky
and they reached a clearing
it came across a clear as they were
driving away
um they
thought about with the the glow that was
illuminating a big part of the forest
was mind-blowing on its own but when
they reached this clearing they noticed
that they appeared to be an object
within the golden globe
um
that they obviously pulled up and it
looked like a little bit it looked like
a disk
so uh you know the truck stopped travis
walton got out and he started to
approach it
um and it was making a high-pitched
buzzing noise
um
his friends our co-workers uh in the
truck told him to you know don't go
don't go there travis stop he got
relatively close apparently uh just a
few feet away from this um object which
then intensified in the pitch of the
buzzing noise that it was making he took
cover behind a log i'll stop in a sec
and then we'll we'll take it up again in
a minute we'll just to have a bit of
interaction with you guys um he took
cover behind a lot a log
it's described as being like um a beam
of energy or almost described as a bolt
of lightning
hit travis walton while he was uh behind
this log
and the rest of the team panicked i'll
carry on with it uh up
in a minute but let's what do you think
so far
i'm wondering what the uh what his mates
were like yelling at him from the truck
dumbass
get in the truck
he's walking up to him no i'm an
american
you're another stoney treatment
there's all in these stories there's
always one idiot that gets out the truck
in there there's always an idiot gets
out of the truck
i think i'm wondering if like trucks are
idiot bait you ever i mean
sometimes i'm sitting in traffic and i
look around i'm surrounded by trucks
something
i see a trend here
so some of those i remember being in
america and i was uh driving an rv and
it was a bit big and i was we
accidentally drove into los angeles
nearly my heart
[Music]
and i just remember we came this close
to hitting a truck at a beautiful f-150
or something but it was from in the back
window there was a just a rifle we were
in a city a rifle across the back window
and i was just like
we came back close and mostly
yeah the the
that's the gist of how the whole thing
started these guys had this uh lumber
contract up in the woods and i think it
was apache sit greaves
national ports yeah yeah yeah
and
uh travis saw some shining woods and
just went for it you know
and um
for and that's kind of how the movie
goes i mean that's that's the the story
about um
you know travis is missing he's gone
he's been beamed up and then here's all
these
you know
lumberjacks in arizona
you know trying to tell the story to the
sheriff and the sheriff's
kind of you got to think he's skeptical
you know and the film shows he's
skeptical
and i think in the film there's like
some discussion of family schisms and
so forth but yeah that's kind of how
that's that whole
that first act of the film went
so he's supposed to have been beamed up
to the ship do they actually other
witnesses actually see him sort of get
taken up no things get hit by the light
so you sit by the light and there's just
what i've gone they they seem get hit
they see him get struck
they get out of there
they drive away
they bravely bravely run
yeah they absolutely
they're out they're out of there they
stop and have it and i'll go through
what travis reports seeing when he was
when he wakes up in a second and but
yeah basically they they got out of
there they screeched to a halt when they
were safely out of the way they had a
little bit of a conflab about what they
should do and what was
um had a bit of an argument and then
decided to go back and retrieve said
travis of course when they got back to
the clearing where travis said that his
uh
beam of light x experiment if you like
um he was he was there no longer he
disappeared he wasn't he wasn't to be
found
okay so back in the town then the
sheriff
thought it was not true possibly well
they haven't got there yet but yes
so what happens when they're heading
back then
well
there's massive arguments about um how
they're going to explain it to the
sheriff if you believe
um what
what we're told
um
but of course i don't jump too far ahead
to theories what people have put forward
as to why
they took their time getting back
because they didn't report it for two
hours
okay they didn't immediately report you
know you would sort of like to think
that if somebody or you saw somebody get
struck by
a ufo or anything for that matter um and
you was concerned and i remember
they were two family friends the rogers
were family friends of travis walton
they weren't just workmates they were
family friends and you would like to
think that they would be concerned
enough to raise the alarm that's
something that happened to their
co-worker and friend but they waited a
couple of hours they've been called
they've been um you know
it has been mentioned and they've been
doubted because of that but you know
we'll come up with that a little bit
later on but the story obviously carries
on then because now now travis is on
board
if you like whatever it is that he
reports and he wakes up in pain
on the table this is what he's reported
to say what i'm saying is what i'm going
through here by the way everybody is
what travis walton has said has happened
okay there is other events within the
film
that don't necessarily correspond what
travis walton said happened um but there
you go he woke up in pain on the table
in a hospital kind of room and there
were three small bald creatures with
really large eyes that were looking at
him um
and he freaked out he panicked he didn't
know because he was in pain or because
he didn't know where he was he he became
panicky and he jumped up and tried to
escape one of the creatures came towards
him apparently to stop him from getting
out the room and he pushed that away
very very easily so it was it was very
very easy to push away he managed to put
that creature out of the way
and he picked up a beaker like a
cylinder a glass beaker or what you
presumably a glass cylinder from a shelf
behind him and started to wave it around
and they retreated these
small bald creatures retreated and then
a taller one came in
that was wearing like a fishbowl kind of
helmet
and was which was more human looking
which calmed him down
this creature then took him into another
room
uh which he said
was actually a completely different
structure from what the craft was
uh where there was a metallic another
metallic table and more of these
creatures were these human type
creatures and one of them was a female
they were all wearing masks plastic
all
masked with tubes in and the female
humanoid creature approached him while
he was laying on this metallic table and
put the mask on him and then he drifted
into unconsciousness the next thing he
remembers is waking up five days and
six hours later or something and near
herbert in arizona in the woods right at
the side of the main road
he looked up and he saw the saucer
disappear just he looked up just to see
disappear from view he then walked to a
call box and phoned his sister so
take it away guys was there any injuries
or anything like that sustained or
anything any injuries or was he ever did
he have a medical examination when he
returned he had a red mark on his arm
which he
posited the theory that it must have
been where there was some kind of
intravenous
tube given to him um where he was being
fed nutrients while he was there for the
five days because it was only he he sort
of made claims that he was only awake
for actually just a few hours during the
entire five and a half day
time that i was missing the rest of it
it was completely unconscious
the the the thing i i just want to
address the two hour issue
uh
from where they were at
in terms of like air miles from
snowflake
they were about 70 miles
air miles
now
here in the american west
you if you're if you're out in the
middle of nowhere and you're away from a
paved road
the the
the area
the whole region is crisscrossed with
old wagon trails and logging trails
and getting up and down those is really
time consuming really time consuming
like yesterday we were up in the sierra
mountains
just driving around and it took about an
hour to go
15 miles
that was on a paved road you know it's
just so twisty and turny that you really
can't get up any speed
and so if they were 70 miles away and
they rolled into town you know two hours
later
well that would
probably be accurate if they left right
i mean you know these and then if you
get off-road well
you know you it's it is
slow going it's very slow going
um and obviously we're talking
when did this happen sorry 75
sometime
so i mean it was um
yeah i mean
they weren't phoning anybody in the
mobiles were they were there they would
have had cb though probably would there
be big number jacks up in the woods
i don't know really i mean you know i
don't know i can't imagine though there
was a conversation
should we tell him he was just eaten by
a bear
i'm thinking eaten by a bear might work
right or we had an argument you just ran
off drunk
let's not go with what actually happened
here people because
yeah i can imagine
they're going to think with doolally
to say the least um
well you know if they were frightened
let's take them afterward i mean they
passed a bunch of polygraphs
you know if they were frightened i mean
you know that kind of panic of seeing
your buddy blasted by this thing in the
air that you're pretty sure is not jesus
i mean it's got to put
faith in jesus
a lot of fear into them
you know no one denied that they weren't
racing down the mountain trying to get
out of the woods and back to town i mean
then you know they probably had to stop
someplace like you said
dave they had to you know try to get
their story straight and
not just get their story straight is
like do they tell the truth or not
that's very true i mean ian makes a good
point here that this this did happen
before
maybe before sci-fi was big but i mean
after
the earth stood still and things like
that so
and i mean ufo flack was in the 50s
wasn't it so i mean that was this was in
the culture there wasn't it's flying
sources
abductions though how many productions
had been reported before this one of the
biggest ones in history better in barney
hill
which this story you could argue is
actually quite similar and i do have to
say i was going to wait until later on
to to say this but
um there was an nbc special that was
aired two weeks before travis walton's
case where they actually it was two-hour
special that was about the betty and
barna hill abduction travis walton
admitted to having seen that travis
walton was also a massive ufo and flying
saucer geek and all his friends
knew about that he was massively into
the flying saucer scene this wasn't new
to him anyway shape our farm
it has so many similarities with
that case
the the way that some of the the the
so-called entities look the way that
they're dressed in overalls the small
ones in reddish brown uniforms the tall
one in dark blue ones that look more
humanoid
the ones that are more calm and human
looking there's so many similarities and
crossovers between the two and just two
weeks on top of which the forestry
commission hounding mike rogers to
complete his contract for which he was
getting fined per acre of woodland that
he was not deforesting and and
withholding 10 percent of the money he
still told the crew
wages that he wasn't able to pay and
when did the contract run out on the
20th
when did
when did travis reappear on the 21st so
there's also the theory um
it's a case of well
i can't um i can't i can't go back
you're gonna have to cancel the contract
i can't go back into the woods because
of these ufos there and i'm scared
please cancel the contract uh because i
can't complete the work because it's
dangerous and that is what happened by
the way
14 days after that the forestry
commission did cancel the contract and
he did get his money that he was old so
some people suspect that that's what
went on there's also other other things
that travis walton can be called into
conjecture regarding his honesty he was
done in 1971 for fraud um yeah
for fraudulent checks he was also done
for burglary with um i think it was it
george rogers and georgia rogers is the
brother of mike rogers who was the team
leader of that group on the night so
he's got a criminal record and they were
offered the chance to reimburse or you
know give the money back
they did
so then they could they could plead not
guilty so that their criminal records
could be expunged we've still got a
doubt the veracity of his claims because
he's a proven
you know fraudster yeah there was at
least one thing that did make it into
the movie is like you know the
the people involved you know were there
was a schism between it they didn't come
out and talk about the fraud
specifically but they
everybody was like kind of on edge and
no one was anybody's real friend
but you know that kind of
you know everybody beating up
on each other and the issue about money
and not getting paid
why in the world would they come up with
such an outlandish story and stick to it
you'd think that you know once they got
paid they'd like well yeah that's a
bunch of [ __ ] especially when travis
pops back up naked in the field or
wherever
you know so why continue and we're or
you know
the rest of them didn't really publish
books or
you know
stuff
yeah they just kind of like well let's
go drop down some more trees because i
got a bills to pay you know it's
i don't know it just seems
with
you know if they're all chums you know i
mean three of us i'm pretty sure we
could come up with some pretty outlander
stories and stick to it
but we kind of like each other you know
and but these guys were not in chums
they weren't best friends you know
as far as we know
that they
so when we say that so is there more is
there any physical evidence other than a
red mark on his arm to support
his story
the um
this is one of the things i was planning
to go out there
up to the clearing where they were the
alleged abduction took place
because there's uh some anomalies in the
trees that were in the area
and we're going to measure those but
then you know covered
but as i understand it there's some
anomalous um
growth in the trees
and i was gonna do like uh uh
tree ring samples but
when they uh
we will see you later thank you so much
for getting up at 3am see you later
go to bed lord we can watch it later
when they arranged the search parties to
look for travis when they realized he
was missing
of course the first place they went to
was the place where he was last saw
which was clearly which was which was
the clearing um there was no signs of
anything because of course they've gone
there and gone look we've got nothing to
do with him he was taken by a big by a
spaceship inside a glowing light so the
first thing they looked for there was
well where's the spaceship that's no
longer here then is there any burn marks
on the ground because they've been ufo
you've got a michelac with the burns on
his body from the 1950s the mcconville
cases there's plenty of ufo sightings
leading up to 1975 many many many many
many in fact um and so you know he's
like well if you're gonna make
outlandish claims like that boy we're
gonna check the land you know what i
mean and they got there and the other
look around and at that time they didn't
find anything whatsoever the search
spread
hmm
and then eventually peter out after a
couple of days pretty much because his
family
weren't that bothered about finding him
you know then they sort of like said uh
in fact
anyway i'm not sure i'd be bothered
about finding him um that's a that is a
fair comment his mum said
i have got it somewhere if you bear with
me one sec
the actual statement is his mum said
there was a it was interesting to say
the least
uh
i can't he find it well something along
the lines of uh i don't know i don't
know why i don't know i don't know why
we're bothering because we're not going
to find him and his brother um made a
statement of something like oh it's okay
because ufos always return victims to
the place they were last found
so was he found near where
he was lost
uh but just a few miles away yeah just
within a couple of miles
and then obviously that would have been
he was on the highway right yeah he was
near the highway yeah so that's yeah
yeah
i would have been interested to know
what the other four or five people were
up to during that time
if it was if this is just
a swiss right they could have said he's
there
this is this is where it happened he
could have been in a tent 20 miles away
couldn't he yeah
well i will say this
the the rest of them sorry jay brother
the rest of them when they went back to
town were not held
for that full time inside a saloon bar
by paranoid sheriffs and the lara
enforcement they weren't kept there for
the full six you know five and a half
six days while travis was away like can
sometimes come across in the way that
the film's um portrayed and the way that
documentaries are made out they were
under suspicion yes they were heavily
questioned yes
but
you know they pretty much kept a low
profile and there is reports as well
that one of them was approached by the
fbi enough for ten thousand dollars to
keep his mouth shut but that's what
travis said so whether that actually
happened or not
i'd like that
backed up back um by the actual person
from what i'm aware of since the event
and we'll go back but travis walton has
done a lot of interviews and things i
think he's even appeared on joe rogan
hasn't he yeah yeah
yeah um but
the others haven't particularly
is that right
yeah
yeah i mean it's just like you know
travis is the only one that's really
talking about it you know and the rest
is just like oh god jesus you know i've
got other things to do
but they but they still don't say it's
bs
yeah they've not come out because that's
the one thing if these guys are
genuinely not in on it together they've
not wanted to get involved since
um
why are they saying it's true so i i
think are two possibilities there either
they were in on it they're better mates
than they think
and
they
they lied so they feel like they can't
on you know
or truth
or
um this was some sort of hoax as in he
got out the truck there was something
rigged the travis wong managed to rig
something so it looked like
you know at least one of them must have
been in on it for that to work though
and then you know everyone's like you
know you know we never said college
didn't we one person starts going oh my
god oh my god
everybody else starts panicking and you
you know you take her out
um
other than that the only other
possibility is obviously that it's true
that i can think of and he was actually
kidding by aliens um
what do you guys think so also what do
you think the actual possibilities are
of
what it could have been if it's not
aliens then
troops man
um
that was straight straight in for the
kill very early on there jay
yeah but i'm excited so i'm trying to
get it around the edge head around it
two hours
um i
the the the last been tell that
hunters and fishermen on the night in
question 5th of november in 1975 also
reported seeing
what appeared to be an amber or golden
glow in the in the sky
those kind of things have sort of been
propagated throughout media by people
in more modern times
rather than at the time
and none of them claims have been
substantiated that i'm aware of and if
they have been substantiated please you
know type it inside chat or type it
under the video when it goes out and i'm
as far as i'm aware they haven't been
actually substantiated that other people
did do it but there are rumors that
fishermen and hunters saw the golden
globe so if they did see the golden glow
that makes that part of the story true
and if that part of the story is true
where there's a golden glow
causing the fire in the sky if you like
then why would
the golden globe be responsible for
travis
also not be true
why why elaborate upon that you know
could they have seen the the golden glow
and it was something uh meteorological
perhaps um that they weren't aware of
and then added the story to that
thinking other people will see this
golden glow as well so this is a perfect
opportunity for us to make up a ufo
story it seems a little bit far-fetched
but you know i i think it's a hoax
personally
sorry
i mean no but but if he was hoaxing it
do you think the other guys were in on
it then
yes
so this is a this was and now they they
can't tell the truth because
they've lied
i think you think one of them
oh you know this this no this was
[ __ ]
well mike rogers is not even willing to
talk about it now i've i've been
involved in
you know when i've had experiences have
seen things that i can't explain whether
it's
on investigations regarding the
paranormal and even just in everyday
life where a certain event has happened
and
somebody's been with me noticed it and
not only will they completely deny
outright that it's happened they won't
even be willing to speak about it's like
no no you know i don't even want to
confront the issue whether it's positive
or negatively biased towards what
actually happened or not they just don't
want to speak about it because it's
going to have caused some kind of trauma
to them because whichever way you look
at it they still did have to answer
questions for five days and undergo a
polygraph i'm gonna get into polygraphs
but we will a little bit but polygraphs
you know chocolate fire guards
um
well you know
when you do them when you arrange it
when you arrange a polygraph the thing
is is the the the examinees
are present when it comes to formulating
the questions
okay so there is the the
there's like an interview or an
assessment at the beginning
um where obviously you will get like um
some kind of um
you know establish what will be a
positive answer by asking questions that
you already know the answer to and this
carries on for any kind of investigation
you know you will
you know i know where this person lives
but i will ask where this person lives
because when i get a response i get a
baseline that baseline can be positive
or negative but i'm using this baseline
as a positive they answer correctly you
know yourself polygraph tests
that they what they they they measure
respiration and heart rate perspiration
response
you know and so the the measure of
physiological changes to psychological
conditioning or psychological
questioning and the anxiety of just
going through
a question
heavy questions could raise anxiety
whether it's positive or negative and
cause physiological changes anyway and
isn't truly an indication of
deception per se that's why they're not
admissible
yeah whether they're completely
unadmissible in this country in
particular i think some states in
america do allow them don't there's
evidence in certain circumstances
um yeah but even in the us where they
allow
i mean sidekicks can probably go to
court and give evidence in some parts of
america though so let's be honest
um that's
that's your word stormy not mine
is it not true though
well i think the legal system is a
little
looser than ours anyway but ours is very
just still very you know we still wear
wigs from the 19 you know from the 1850s
it is a 1700s yeah yeah probably i i
nearly said 1950s i
don't know where that was going
remember british history is american
history up until 1776 and then you guys
drop off the face and beyond mister
and beyond don't just believe the lie
about the teabags being thrown into the
hudson river it goes beyond that you've
still got our judicial system pretty
much in our education we stole it from
the
the
romans
river and the boston
harbor is completely different places
you forgive me for knowing that
erroneous little bit of american history
i'm surprised any americans know
anything about british history
like i said it's taunting schools up
until 1776. that was the common history
i believe though
but after that man
it's all paul revere and
on real
history there is the real stuff
so i always love that story about when
the americans were building disneyland
or when disney was building disneyland
and they came over to build euro disney
they were trying to build a castle and
somebody went
we'd better build this a bit bigger
they've actually got castles here
we better put a bit more effort into
this guys
they've got some
um
okay so i'm still trying to get me a try
on this story right so we've got i mean
this is still one of the most famous
cases is is it basically famous because
there were five witnesses and that's
quite rare i think so
it's just not one guy stumbling out of
the woods
you know
yeah and then
i mean because in most
ufo cases let's be honest or
particularly old ones it's either the
person it's happened to betty and barney
hill
they weren't any other real witnesses i
don't think there are any other
witnesses are they
except betty and barney because they
were on the road in the middle of
nowhere
there was some physical evidence
so this doesn't have any physical
evidence really other than a red mark in
his arm
it's got five witnesses
witnesses that don't necessarily like
each other witnesses that don't
haven't tried to cash in on it since
well as far as i'm aware um when he when
he you know it was like i said he phoned
his sister from a car box he was
retrieved
um
[Music]
he was
not emaciated but you could tell he
hadn't eaten he was unshaven he was
you know you could go out roughing it
and do that i suppose you could you
couldn't impose them upon yourself by
limiting your calorie intake over a few
days we're just having enough sustenance
to survive
if that was the way that you wanted to
go i mean if you're thinking i'm going
to go disappearing for a few days and i
need to make sure that i look like i've
been missing for a few days you're not
going to sit there eating pizzas 24 7.
uh you you know you're going to be aware
that you need to drop your calorie
intake off but you did that thinking it
through though that's really thinking
through
well they did have a few weeks to think
it through because like i say
the the idea could have been formulated
from the mbc special which is two weeks
in advance mike rogers knew um that he
wasn't he'd already asked for an
extension from the forestry commission
and the forestry commission had added
that one dollar per acre that fell under
the dateline or rather the deadline of
the forest commission's extension that
would be in the race plus the the money
that there was withholding so
i don't know
i'm amazed i got away with it
so what we're basically saying here is
if i can break it down really simply
we've got no physical evidence
we've got a guy who ran it who had been
done for fraud
and um
and had other criminal things they had a
fine standard handing out hanging over
them that would have cost them i imagine
they're not wealthy people
um that they maybe couldn't afford if
they ran over this contract if they
didn't fulfill the contract he was
making something like 25 an acre it was
being fined a dollar an acre for every
acre that was
not deforested beyond that beyond the
extension plus a day right when they're
producing
yeah yeah
plus the the workers that you had to pay
you had to pay their wages they weren't
doing it for free
so
that was coming out with a 25 it might
have been a little bit more i'm sure you
can find it on the internet guys if you
want to check out it's there about 25
something like that so he's losing money
all the time and the forestry
commissioner withholding a big chunk of
the money until completion of the
contract so i mean that gives him motive
i mean i'm thinking about motive means
an opportunity so they had they had the
information they have the betting buying
hill story he's a huge euphonia so he
actually believes this stuff
um i was thinking when these people
found out to be frauds
um particularly a lot of ufos
supernatural ghost blue they believe the
line and if you believe a lie it's
really easy to
talk yourself
to continue and propagate the line um
i think in the back of the redstone
where they go well this didn't really
happen but it could it should you know
it could have happened so why not just
yeah
i mean psychologically speaking people
due to the human condition to help you
know when you when you suffer trauma you
know there's the difference between
academic memory and emotional memory and
so when something happens and somebody
has an emotional memory the thing is is
the the amygdala is responsible for the
processing of the the actual facts that
are going in at that time so the late
today what what people will do is they
will as they tell the story it's
the human condition are natural to
slightly embellish every time they say
it to help solidify the story over time
because the academic memory wasn't
responsible for storing the information
when it happened it was the emotional
memory because of the final flight
kicking in which is a natural response
for for a human being so it's normally
it's completely natural for stories to
slightly become embellished when they're
completely truthful whenever they're
completely factual and they don't change
throughout the course of of their being
told they're completely the same all the
time they're almost memorized
practiced studied
i don't think there's there was only one
fire in the sky movie wasn't there but
this is a story this and a
formula to it that's been repeated a lot
in like x-files and and
there's a scene from x-files it's almost
identical to this in the first series
isn't even in the opening credits with a
character being hit by light and being
sort of pulled up by his chest
the the thing i find interesting is that
there was a thing of fire in the area
a woodland fire like 2000 early 2000s i
think
and uh
some before the fire somebody went out
and got tree ring samples
and the tree ring sample showed that
around the time that he was counting
back the rings
the uh
trees in that area experienced higher
growth faster growth in the
tree rings of the surrounding forest
yeah also the soil samples kind of in
the middle of this ring of trees
what had a lot of higher iron content
than other sample soils from the
mountainside
and that's
interesting
you know uh wasn't it evidence of ball
lightning maybe or something else
i mean i'm just trying from a scientific
point of view trying to narrow other
things that could have happened is the
is the uh hematite the magnet
yes he did yes he did yeah
so something was so we're arguing that
something around this time
happened could have been something these
guys witnessed though i mean you know
ball lightning is incredibly rare there
was no way they could have known that
was going to happen
um but maybe they saw a meteorite maybe
they saw
particularly in the pitch black i mean
if you go somewhere that's dark enough
and look up you will see constant
streaks and areas
um yeah
could something have happened that they
saw that they maybe inspire them and
think you know what actually if we say
there was a ufo incident now
somebody will say they saw lights in the
sky
and they will back us up
i don't know
i think it's just as plausible as
anything else i mean that's what i
that's what i was almost alluding to
just a little bit earlier myself you
know
if fishermen and hunters saw a golden
glow in the sky and they all witnessed
the same thing it's a little bit easier
to elaborate upon
something that other people may have
seen as well to gain corroborative
reassurance within the community that
what happened truly did and build upon
that but
just throw a spanner in the works travis
walton also uh when he's been
interviewed has also made other
statements that i've got
that other events have happened to him
when he was a child he woke up in the in
the middle of the night um and due to
the heat because that time of year they
were all sleeping inside a corridor his
family and he he woke up because he saw
a small small man um that was at
the foot the foot of his bed and was
lifting up the bed clothes which
sort of like uh made him like jump up
and then this small small ball that he
pretty much describes it like uh the the
small creatures that are on board the
craft if you like
um
he he saw this small
man dressed in dark clothes
big eyes big head
um hairless
and then he disappeared
he also reported that when he oh yeah oh
yeah starmie baby he also reported
when he was older and this is after the
event he woke up for no reason and he
was running he was running out of his
bedroom and he's woke up running
and he's run straight into his child's
bedroom and he's noticed that he son is
choking himself on the rail of the car
of the crib and he managed to
enable him to save his son's life as if
some kind of extraterrestrial spirit
guide he's watching over him you know um
so we these things have come out now in
in many cases of abductions are where
you will get generational abductees
yeah and a cd brian and i did well
there's others but cd brown's doing a
lot of work
and wrote a lot of books about this kind
of thing
um
where
and bud hopkins especially
and
multiple generations of people will be
abducted or if people do get abducted
they want just to be abducted once
there's these lots of i i want to say
evidence to use the term loosely
evidence but there's lots of reports of
people
anecdotally conducted as children as
teens as grown-ups and then their
children get abducted too and that type
of
you know as that was um given more
exposure because people like buddhopkins
in the in the
you know the 80s and into the early 90s
travis is story
started to change
to adapt to fit that narrative as well
um as if that would reinforce his
believability of being abducted because
it's like well of course i'm a true
abductee because i've had it when i was
young and i've had it after the event
just like all of the abductees do a
little bit convenient for my liking
did uh when uh
when um
excuse me when the story was retracted
by mike
yeah did he replace it with something
else or he just says no that didn't
happen he walked off
yeah he pretty much did um and and i
think somebody i forget the name and
you'll have to forgive me for for this
it really should have like
got got the name but um he could get
interviewed by somebody else later on
and he said no he sort of like
reinforced his statement again saying it
was true
um
so he's like yes this is what happened
no
two no no you see that's not what
happened to don't talk to me i'm not
interested in what happened to no no
that is what happened again you know
how many days was travis missing
five days six hours i believe
did any
so he just playing devil's advocate
um
did anybody else
come up to say they saw him in those uh
five days
no no one admitted like came forward
saying well i fed the guy
or you know i caught him in my dog
kennel eating the dog food or you know i
mean
so the other question is and you know we
have evidence of tree rings and then all
the scandals but where the hell why
somebody i mean you know you
that's you know it's high altitude it's
spar i mean maybe the the
the native apaches took him in i don't
know it's just or they would have
probably have shot him
so what happened i mean
okay so
let's rule out he wasn't in a ufo well
where the hell was he and the lord knows
there's a big enough bounty hunt you
know thinking he was murdered you know i
think he was wanting it up to the state
level state investigators and not
or did it ever rise to federal
investigation
well yeah the fbi were involved was it
the fbi well
you
somebody would have you know
i would think somebody said well yeah i
saw that sorry son of a [ __ ] over here
you know
let's let's consider it
hive or something yeah let's guess it
was true for a second though because
certainly a good point is it a freaking
abduction spot
i don't think specifically it is but
it's in an area that's not far from new
mexico
not that far from white sands is that
don't think yeah
[Music]
um well i was also thinking about the
ufo corridor isn't that right smack bang
in the middle of the ufo corridor
um so yeah basically
ufo hospital
in a way arizona and like i said arizona
new mexico places like colorado more for
cattle mutilations and things like that
but it is sort of like in in that area a
big biggest chunk of actual abductions
uh actually occurred in europe and not
in the us though
and if i could just speak to the the
issue of the
multiple abductions or whatever
the mountain that they were on this is
going back to the native american lord
the mountain they were on is considered
sacred to the apache
for uh vision quests
in the spirit people
so
there's a lot of crap in the west that
you know that's kind of spooky that you
know we just you know from western
civilization come around and see it and
it's like well no this has been going on
for quite some time i mean
you know you guys have seen my
petroglyph videos and they are some
crazy ones out here
and a lot of them you know it's like you
look at them so well you know maybe
that's abstract art or maybe that's you
know something else maybe that's an
abduction maybe that's
you know uh maybe that's a star map or
something
now if all these petroglyphs are indeed
just abstract art
um there's a valley here in california
that's got to be the biggest abstract
art gallery in the world 600 square
miles on it
and so you know don't discount you know
native american lore how these events
may have been handed down in
in form of stories
that at best that they could know you
know 500 years ago best they could tell
be you know because
rocket science is a relatively new thing
that rocket science is not a thing when
um
in pre-columbian times
so i mean there's there's that also
going for it in terms of explanation i
guess
i think um
sorry jay barnes state i think when you
when you you you're in a situation where
the the family
of travis when they are actually
involved
boots on the ground with the search for
him
aren't bothered about searching for him
the investigators at the time the the
police at the time were massively
concerned about the lack of interest
that the family was showing
in in worrying about his concern like
yeah you know oh he'll be fine
which to them sort of suggested that
there was something arranged they knew
how did they know he was going to be
okay how did they know he was going to
come back and he was going to be fine
how
you know um that means either a they
completely believed out and out that he
had been taken by ufo and they also then
had to completely believe the ufo would
return him completely safely
or they had to have agreed with the fact
that well yeah they murdered him but
it's okay
there isn't really anything else outside
there
yeah
yeah it's like well he's got he's gone
missing it's like well who gives us you
know
who cares and they really
can't remember the statement from his
mum but it was something along the lines
of you know i don't see the point in
carrying on this any further you know
no mother would do that
that's not natural and if she didn't
care about him
and that's uh you know and it's a case
of well why should she be involved in
the search in the first place then so
obviously she did care i had to portray
that she cared to want to go out and be
boots on the ground searching as a
mother would but when questioned about
it you know she wants to call it off
just a couple of hours in like ah forget
it you know it's pointless looking
if it's bs i think that makes sense
because if i was thinking we're in
because
you talked into this lie it's okay we're
going to do this because we want to get
out of this contract and this is going
to happen so i'm just going to hide out
in the woods for a few days and then
we're gonna say it's aliens and she'll
be like no one's gonna believe that but
then when actually
tens or even hundreds of people start
searching and spending all this money
because you might just stood there while
like the search teams got just like
looking around thinking oh when we get
caught we're gonna be in trouble yeah at
least don't worry about it yeah exactly
yeah exactly
um yeah i can completely
appreciate why she was doing that
because she must have been thinking this
is getting out of hand
and that is what
that's what concerned investigators at
the time jay the fact that the family
didn't seem to care
yeah
so i mean
yeah the movie was a dramatization i
think i'd say right yeah i mean even
travis walton since i think
dave you said earlier said look it
wasn't that
violent or it wasn't that it it's not
that [ __ ] he didn't have a weird kind of
s sheet of this weird stuff that was
stretched over the top of him that
prevented him from breathing he didn't
wake up in a cocoon kind of thing with
hundreds of other human beings that were
being stored or anything like that you
know he he woke up he was on a table he
was being watched by three beings he
freaked out he had a little bit of a
scuffle with one a humanoid to come
towards him took him somewhere else
exactly a little bit of the old
queensberry
a humanoid type one took him somewhere
else he strapped him to a table stuck a
mask on him lights out and he remembers
waking up that's the broad outline of it
really he got lost in a frat party
that's what that sounds like yeah they
threw a mask on me man
yeah wow
[Laughter]
we're coming up to the um end of the
show as we always do so let's let's wrap
it up then so we're going to have to
going against the head
is the fire in the sky movie a nice bit
of sci-fi that
is not based on anything that actually
happened or is it
based on a true story as it claims
well i think it's it's a it's a fun
movie that was based on someone's story
that
the veracity i was still kind of up in
here
um
yeah
i think it's fair enough
dave
i think um i think it's a massively
fictionalized movie
on the back of somebody's
story
um
and i think the story is a hoax
so in my opinion it's all a movie it is
all sci-fi if you like
yeah yeah
i think it's a it's an it's i actually
think i i do enjoy remembering the movie
but i've seen other films that like
pretend to do
for me to be like blair witch you know
it's a film that's pretending to be real
and that's why it's more
a little bit scarier sort of things like
well you know and it's it's that sort of
thing and it was very well made you know
we talked about some of the actors good
actors in this film
um it got it got critical acclaim at the
time because i said it really focused on
travis walton's emotional
the impact emotionally of what he went
through
um but i don't i've
i did see travis walton on joe rogan a
bit
he didn't go integrating into the story
but i didn't watch it all to be fair but
um i didn't believe the word he was
saying no
um
all my friends want to go see the movie
and love the movie
yeah you know yeah it's a good film it's
a good movie it's a good movie i've got
to ask though how did the story
not get dismissed as nonsense almost
straight away how did it how do we know
that i mean i know that travis walter
i'm embarrassed as like as a ufo guy
not to know this story properly
i think i don't know it because i think
when i watched the film i just
immediately thought well this isn't true
so i never bothered looking into it a
great deal is the only thing i can think
of i've never researched it
you know you asked me this question
earlier like how do we know
and
one way or the other
and
why why has it stuck around why did it
get a movie
you know if you take the other guys out
of it you know lost lumberjack gets
zapped by ufo reappears in town five
days later
i would i i i wouldn't have
i would have gotten past the second
paragraph like oh okay right you know
proper ufo geeks
yeah i mean it's so complicated and
other people involved and no one found
the guy and you know they did report it
you know right off the bat it wasn't
like he
you know been missing for days and then
someone said something about it
and uh it's just
like well where the hell was he that's i
think that's a valley question you know
who was
who was hiding him who was feeding him
he had to have
at least water you know
um
and okay in family has a very good point
here we should put that up on screen
sounds like much fighting
i am a lung jack and i'm okay
when i do work all day i will say this
though
you have raised a good point there about
where where was it
but there are cabins out there and they
do have supplies out there in case they
get caught now it was already getting
near to winter because it was november
oh there is cold in over here it was it
was already yeah so the the days were
drawing the nights were driving in the
days were becoming shorter
they did they were you know as far as
i'm aware there are cabins out there if
it comes to it hunters
um but in saying that and again playing
devil's advocate towards himself would
they not been searched during the search
for travis
especially if they suspected he was just
hiding out
i mean according to the fbi i mean they
had all sorts of people out looking for
them the sheriff's department look you
know i think even the uh the the apache
reservation
uh they were looking for the guy because
they wanted the federal ollies off their
land responding this white man and get
him out
yeah you know right yeah and we don't
want him traipsing all over our sacred
mountain
and but it is it's just
i think the reason the story has stuck
around and why
you know is just because
it's not
there's lots of evidence about it that's
that can make it easily dismissed you
know there's lots of squirrelly behavior
and all the other stuff
but then again you know it's just
there's so many things that's popped up
about the story that kind of
keeps it alive well you know like one
guy you know discredits it then he
recredits it and but the rest of him
said well now that [ __ ] really happened
or something like that and
then there's differences between his
book and the movie and even the producer
said well now this is too much like
something that's already been on tv
we have to sensationalize it so let's
get some screenwriting to do this in
sedation
if they were really strict to think it
would be boring and a movie is still
entertainment otherwise they'd just do a
documentary
if you um
all you've got to do is and this
happened ten years after i believe i
think it was ten years after um whitley
strieber um when whitley street was it
was abducted and watched the film
communion in relation to the book so
what whitley um reported to have
happened what he's wrote about his
experience to the actual film was it
christopher walken who played him
actually i think maybe has nobody seen
it and they have me on with this one
but um if you watch the film communion
compared with what whitley strieber
reported you'll see it's much of a
muchness it's an elaboration upon
reported event
so just to answer the first question i
did allude to this earlier do you think
then if
it's always possible this is true we
look at the with our cynical minds and
what happened it is possible
he elaborated on it we can't we cannot
say he's a 100 full of [ __ ] we just
can't unfortunately because we weren't
there
no um
but is it what what do you think is more
likely than that he
somehow rigged something to convince
these other five people that somebody
had happened
you know because that would be the best
way of spending a life that's what you
want to do or do anything these all of
these guys were in on this and it's just
a hoax i i don't think travis is smart
enough to rig anything
i know it's harsh and that's cruel but
i don't think he's i don't think he's
smart enough to rig cables and just
i i just don't
um
that's up there isn't it i i agree with
that
i i yeah i agree with that um
no i think
it's just an out and out lie
um and they dropped them off buggered
off when we went aliens
vocalized a vocalized lie it's verbatum
um and you know
while they haven't denied it they
haven't
talked about it
um in any of the experiences i've had i
mean my first one will be 1980s
well when i was a kid but the first one
that i remember that is
cemented in my brain will be 1987.
but
you know
i'm not bothered about talking about it
you know i will talk about it i would
discuss it you know i don't need to deny
it so if it happened why would they go
yeah i put that's it and never speak
about it again or not be interested in
never talking about it if something
happened yeah god damn right it happened
yeah and i'll tell you wow and this is
what happened and we were here and i
felt like this and i couldn't believe
there was [ __ ] in your pants he totally
disappeared man they were freaked out no
there's none of that it's like no no no
no all five of them i wouldn't mind if
like one or two did because not
everybody wants to talk to reporters or
wants to be mocked
but all of them is suspicious and mike
rogers felt complete uh compelled to
talk because he was a lead with the team
and there were all his responsibility
that worked for him
[Music]
now in family in chat brings up an
interesting question
what in the book or when the movie did
he meet another human on board
a human a human type alien yeah he
picked up like a glass beaker from
behind him that was on the shelf that
was when he was in the first room when
he first woke up there you go for glass
beakers see jamie from site on and
available
from side trackers
fans
but yeah he picked up a glass tumbler
speaker and started to wave it around
like a weapon and people our m family of
beggy pardon
the people inside ourselves he was uh he
started waving it around like a weapon
at this uh this this original creature
then backed off there were three of them
in the room with him and it was a
humanoid type
a more human entity that came towards
him to calm him down i was wearing a
fishbowl helmet took him into another
room where there were three one of them
a female and it was the female looking
uh
humanoid more human-looking humanoid if
you like
that calmed him down on the table he had
a mask put on his face and then he went
out that's all that happened everything
else that's pretty much portrayed
of the comments there uh a lot of what
else is portrayed in the film is
artistic license on top of artistic
license i think there you go
so i think that's that's i mean let's
say we this this is only our opinion we
don't know for sure because it is based
on it there are interesting parts of
this story which is i think why like we
said it stuck around and why it got a
movie
but
for me yeah good film
i watch every few years if i ever catch
it on but
it's not not based on true story for me
so there are other far more interesting
stories out there that were less
sensationalized it's the five witnesses
isn't it that basically got it
absolutely and when you get abducted by
aliens they don't take you aboard a nice
little source you get taken aboard a
battle cruiser and they kill you
they don't let you go people then you
die
i tried to get some videos that we could
put little clips and i googled anal
probing thinking i would
went badly wrong if my wife sees my
search history i'm in trouble
um yeah that's the thing about all this
anal problem is that because the zeta
wreck italians are something erected
they seem to be massively like
predisposed towards human beings
[ __ ] which is never fully understood
it's because they all know we talk [ __ ]
they took that literally and
thought well this is where they talk
now this there's interesting yeah
yeah
google be safe
absolutely agree with that yeah i need
to change my settings
you need to define viruses
they're done for now let's learn
um yeah
all right
well that's it guys i think we've
covered that one it's the big story that
we've we've had i've been talking aliens
and stuff on this channel on the machine
channel for about three years and we've
never covered this
so there we go one more down just
scratch that off the list thank you very
much
um have you ever have you ever done a
video
on
a ufo cult
no but we should and we should make one
i want a cult that comes to do my
housework for me yeah and i want to be
the religious leader
um
20 years ago i'd have said if i could
also then get a bunch of virgins but now
i'm married i'm not allowed to do that
sort of thing anymore but if they could
do my housework for me that right
yeah
you know after this off camera i'll i'll
tell you a story and see if you want to
go for it or not did we not uh did we do
this
whole thing in the past j did we do away
call thing i don't know it's not a ufo
call but we were
we did a video on the kool-aid yeah jim
jones thing yeah tim jones we did that
and that was kind of ufo cult
it well it was a ufo cult they believed
it he was just a madman um
and was that they're still the the
largest murder
case in history if you if you've gone
over to murder suicide but there's a 800
or something ridiculous yeah something
like that
but no i don't think we have so we'll
have to do a ufo cult
and then like i said if anybody wants to
come and join the sidetrack call
all you have to do is come and do
housework it's really and pray to me as
your new god
yeah you will do as you are told
you will design sidetrack
you will buy crap
off the side check
side dashcheck.com um
and yeah you will buy my crap and just
do everything i say and um
but nobody wants to join
i wonder why that's why i have children
they i get 15 or so years where they
have to do as they're told
yes
they're cult i always wanted a cult of
my own
anyway guys so it has been lovely as
always
um we'll back next week um champs if you
want to get in the comments after the
video if there's anything you want us to
talk about in future videos uh if you're
a farm side trick please go over to the
machine and subscribe there go over to
cy works and darius dariuslus2 and
subscribe there too
and
if you haven't wandered over to the
twitch account i don't know why i'm on
twitch my son told me to i don't know
what it's for it seems to be a lot of
people playing computer games and other
people watching it
which i don't understand
um but my son said i've got to go on
twitch so we're on twitch too and all
our live streams will be on there so
do all that business like share the
video
have a lovely rest of your sunday
we will see you next week about the same
time saying back to our channel thanks
for having us thank you bye bye
one more question sorry before we go how
was all this connected to the waltons
no
no no not even a bit
no
that's a bit disappointing isn't it i
spent all day watching the waltons
that was the wrong show prep
god damn it now if you want to talk
about grandma's peanut uh
apple butter
i will say
an appalachian lemon
your version your version of the waltons
that you are watching is probably more
believable
yeah well i i googled anal probing
walton's
bad
good night guys